gêné navarette bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin dans la matinale de rtl france
alors on le disait l'obligation du port
du masque divise fortement à la réunion
quels sont les arguments avancés par les
parents qui refusent le port du masque
pour les élèves
alors c'est pas nouveau que ça divise en
ça divise depuis depuis le commencement
depuis le début de l'année sur l'élément
terre en tout cas sur les enfants que de
6 ans les arguments déjà en est à la
réunion à la réunion connaît pas l'hiver
à la réunion ce matin à 8 heures il
faisait déjà 28 degrés donc on a nos
enfants qui sont en classe dans des
classes qui sont pas forcément climatisé
rarement climatisé d'ailleurs parfois
avec le ventilateur ou pas et qui
doivent supporter pendant que plusieurs
heures d'affilée un masque
à masquer apportez donc il ya déjà sept
cet argument là qui est déjà basique
pour nous tout en sachant que sur la
métropole au mois de juin quand il a
commencé à faire ch en métropole et ben
effectivement ces 10 en métropole à bas
les enfants chaud donc on va éviter on
va enlever le port du masque alors que
nous ça n'a jamais changé donc c'est un
des arguments va dire ça mais en france
le port du masque n'a été enlevée que
dans certains départements où il est
aussi reculé peut finalement dans métro
alors sur d'harwell il me semble que
juste avant les vacances de juillet sur
les deux trois semaines selon les
départements ça a été enlevé non pas du
tout mais justement qu'en est il de la
circulation du virus chez les enfants
est ce que vous constatez beaucoup de
contamination qu'est ce qu'on sait des
chiffres sur place alors concernant les
enfants moi je suis incapable de vous
les donner lancé rien où on voit les
taux d'incidence c'est tout ce qu'on
accepte en tout cas nous donner comme
information
on a nos taux de notre taux d'incidence
qui avait ses drastiques dapra strict
mans
/ début octobre on est descendu à moins
de 30 ans taux d'incidence donc on a eut
ensuite les vacances scolaires et à la
rentrée des vacances scolaires c'était
il ya deux semaines il me semble ils ont
enlevé le port du masque donc on était
content après des mois de combats et on
a eu ça pendant une seule petite semaine
et au bout d'une petite semaine
l'incidence a redémarré donc
il ya des écoles qui ont fermé justement
des classes en tout cas qui ont fermé
pendant cette période
là récemment je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas qu'est-ce que déplorer le fait que
le gouvernement à paris ne ne fasse pas
la différence du se montre ses
spécificités chez vous et en métropole
alors oui il ya de ça totalement il ya
des spécificités de forcément selon les
régions à prendre en compte sa wii et
dans tous les cas de manière nationale
nous ce que toutes les associations de
parents réclament ces des études
d'impact c'est savoir quelles sont
vraiment ses impacts sur ce port de
masques prolonger chez des enfants qui
en six ans 7 ans 8 ans même 12 ans voilà
nos a vu ton van porte et on va le
porter au bureau selon les métiers qu'on
peut faire on va pouvoir enlever on va
pouvoir respirer faire une pause et
c'est l'enfant est liée sur toute sa
journée il peut l'enlever que à la
cantine pour manger et puis de le
remettre à le temps de la récréation
dans la salle de classe fin c'est
insupportable est ce qu'on dénonce
également c'est selon les établissements
effectivement c'est pas partout mais
selon l'établissement alors on va avoir
des chefs d'établissement et des
enseignants qui sont qui reste humain
malgré tout don qui savent voilà à
trouver le juste milieu entre le
protocole qui peut être appliquée et la
réalité terrain et on va avoir des
moments insupportable de la pression qui
est mise sur les enfants des enfants qui
se font hurler dessus s'ils ont le
masque en souvenez des enfants qui sont
se font punir qui ont des notes
spéciales cos vide fin c'est
insupportable que c'est quoi c'est notre
spécial coville dont vous nous parlez
alors selon ben c'est selon les
enseignants il ya des notes seul dans
les établissements d notre candide de
comportement donc ben ciel ça influe
donc y perdre des points si au bout de
quelques fois plusieurs fois on leur
demande de remettre leur masse
correctement sur le nez ils perdent des
points comportement il ya carrément on a
eu des témoignages d'enfants ou chez les
enseignants qui enlèvent des points sur
des notes normal un contrôle un point en
moins parce que il en a marre de répéter
à l'enfant de remettre son masque
correctement finalement qu'est ce que
vous dites que c'est aux adultes de
faire attention et pas aux enfants
moi je pense qu'on fait porter une
grosse responsabilité aux enfants
j'aimerais sincèrement pas être un
enfant ni être un adolescent là en cette
période
on a des ans des enfants qui viennent
vers nous associations qui sont
terrorisés de retourner à l'école qui
n'ont pas envie qu'ils ne connaissent
pas leurs camarades qu'ils subissent de
la pression toute la journée donc oui
c'est beaucoup trop pour les enfants
d'autant plus que dans les études
d'impact il ya la fameuse balance
bénéfice risque qu'on attend toujours de
connaître entre tous que ça ça fait
porter aux enfants les conséquences pour
eux sur leur vote leur santé et à la
fois physique et psychologique est en
face quels sont les risques finalement
est ce qu'ils sont vraiment vecteur de
cette maladie ou pas parce qu'on leur
fait croire en tout cas qu'ils sont
vecteurs et que s'ils ne mettent pas en
masse correctement ils seront malades et
y rendre malade du coup comment ça se
passe à partir d'aujourd'hui vous
boycotter cette mesure est ce que vous
êtes nombreux
nous on appelle tout tous les parents
tout simplement à retrouver leur rôle de
parents et à se mobiliser si si il pense
comme noah parce que chacun est en droit
de penser comme ils le souhaitent
certains souhaitent mettre leurs masques
au leurs enfants mais qu'ils le mettent
qu'ils soient ensuite si ce sens en
sécurité comme ça très bien mais s'il ya
des parents qui ne sont pas d'accord
avec ça on estime quand même que c'est
aussi aux parents de pouvoir choisir
pour leurs enfants et quand on a aussi
les enfants qui ont les certificats
médicaux qui attestent qu'ils ne doivent
pas normalement porter le masque sur
toute la journée qui pourrait
éventuellement y avoir une dérogation
pour une porte de vivières ou quelque
chose comme ça enfin trouver un juste
milieu des enfants qui sont asthmatiques
qui ont des problèmes
cutanés qui font des crises d'épilepsie
et des choses comme ça et qu'on voit que
c'est des certificats médicaux qui sont
pas acceptés par les établissements ni
par les inspections etc on se demande où
est ce qu'on va donc nous on appelle au
boycott on appelle son faux parents à
reprendre leur place de parents aux
médecins reprendre leur place de
médecins est à dire ok qu'est ce qu'on a
en face oui il ya la co vide qui existe
effectivement ok mais est ce que le jeu
en vaut la chandelle entre tout ce qu'on
sacrifie à côté en loi ya la question de
la vaccination des enfants de 5 à 11 ans
est ce que pour vous ça pourrait être
une solution pour éviter d'avoir toutes
ces mesures contraignantes à l'école
non
réponse est claire merci beaucoup en
tout cas de mercy génie navarette de
nous avoir répondu en direct ce matin
dans la matinale de rtl france